chez opéra bonsoir danse pas vous êtes
grand reporter à paris match et vous
couvrez depuis 15 ans tous les conflits
de la planète du nicaragua à
l'afghanistan en passant par la
tchétchénie et le 9 octobre 2001 deux
jours après le début des frappes
américaines en afghanistan vous êtes
arrêté par les talibans accusés
d'espionnage et vous encourez la peine
de mort vous serez emprisonnait 26 jours
avant d'être libérée et d'y retourner
pour retrouver votre géôliers celui qui
vous a sauvé la vie et découvrir que
vous aviez en fait échappé de justesse à
la mort et puis aussi on en parlera
qu'oussama ben laden que les américains
cherchaient par tous était en fait
tranquillement à djalalabad à moins d'un
kilomètre de votre prison voilà vous
raconter tout ça dans un livre qui
paraît chez pauvert qui s'appelle poste
numéro trois hôtes des talibans par
michel terrain
michel peyrard merci d'avoir choisi tout
le monde en parle pour en parler
interview vérité
alors le 8 octobre la veille de votre
capture vous êtes à peshawar vous
regarder la télévision des images de la
guerre et vous dites c'est très bien
écrit le bouquin vous dit d'emblée j'ai
détesté cette guerre si discourtoise
qu'elle s'invite et un dimanche soir
veille de bouclage il n'y a pas pire y a
pas pire parce qu'on n'a pas le temps on
n'a pas le temps de travailler alors
votre bouquin c'est une réflexion sur la
guerre aussi vous dites j'aime couvrir
la guerre j'en aime les mauvais goût les
cadavres exhibé il ya un plaisir à
couvrir la guerre moi je trouve que dans
le dans la guerre il y a il ya une des
sociétés qui se dégage des décotes des
usages nos sociétés occidentales sont
réfugiés sont très codifié dans la
guerre souvent les gens ne se la joue
plus ce n'est plus la peine de se la
jouer parce que la vie est par essence
éphémère donc les masques tombent j'ai
l'impression parfois que le centre de
gravité le mas des places et j'aime la
vérité des gens à ce moment là dans la
guerre se donne de l'intensité à la vie
c'est ça qui vous fascine d'une certaine
façon les journalistes trouvent leur
compte dans leur guerre dans la guerre
c'est pas la peine de se raconter des
histoires on aime ça ouais et puis à
cette idée d'aller voir soi-même c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui les états majors
organise des voyages 1
ce qu'on appelle le pool c'est à dire
pour un certain nombre de journalistes
et les trimbale comme ça ils leur
montrent ce qu'ils veulent bien leur
montrer et vous pendant la guerre du
koweït avec des copains vous aviez fait
un anti poule qui s'appelait fuck de
poule et et vous y alliez sans être
guidé par les militaires par les
militaires américains et alors il ya un
truc extraordinaire quand vous êtes
arrivé à koweït city il était déguisé en
militaire est arrivé avant le pool de
journalistes et vous ai découvert toutes
les supercheries qui était monté à
l'usagé des journalistes où
effectivement nous quand on est arrivé
on n'a pas découvert la quatrième armée
du monde qu'on nous vendait le package
package mais de mediative des américains
nous disait que c'était on allait à on
allait voir ce qu'on allait voir c'est
et adolf hitler avait fait avec saddam
hussein l'amérique a toujours eu des
s'attend donc ça a été noriega ça était
kadhafi puisse arrêter saddam hussein je
crois que l'amérique par définition a
besoin d'eux a besoin de se découvrir
comme ça des ennemis à noter d'ailleurs
que ce sont souvent d'anciens amis de
julie qu envoyer l'armée irakienne soit
disant la quatrième armée du monde en
fait vous découvrez que c'est dégueu
comme vous dites dans votre book à des
enfants désarmés démotivés et puis avait
aussi une fausse salle de supplices qui
avait été montée à usage des
journalistes sert lorsqu'on est arrivé à
koweit city on a découvert à l'hôpital
moubarak de du centre ville une morgue
où il y avait des gens qui avaient été
supprimés supplier suppliciés de torture
l acide il y avait huit ou une dizaine
de cadavres je crois
trois ou quatre jours après tout ça
avait été organisée pour les besoins du
pool pour montrer à la presse américaine
et acier annan en particulier à quel
point saddam hussein était un set était
satan et s'attend alors à peshawar c'est
pas en militaires que vous déguiser
cette fois c'est un talibane c'est à
dire que vous essayez une burqa alors
c'est très intéressant d'ailleurs parce
que vous savez porter une burqa et vous
dites que d'abord cette vision
effectivement grillagé et en plus elles
n'ont pas le droit de tourner la tête à
droite ou à gauche parce que finalement
elles doivent pas regarder l'homme donc
elles sont un peu comme des chevaux qui
auraient des ornières qui auraient des
ornières elles n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir un regard pour leurs geôliers
pour les hommes
il ya effectivement beaucoup d'accidents
par exemple sur les sur les routes en
afghanistan parce que d'une part le
cadre grillagée limites expliquant la
vision et d'autre part ils peuvent pas
tourner la tête ouais alors vous faites
un essai vous faites une incurie
fonctionne à vous partez du pakistan et
en afghanistan dans une ville et qui
s'appelle rost qui est très important
mouais place force stratégique des
taliban là vous gérer ça marche et là
vous vous dites ça y est maintenant je
vais toujours habillé en
italie bahn je vais aller à kaboul mais
vous avez quand même un pressentiment
vous avez une espèce de près en position
1 je sens pas ce matin là il ya une
succession d'événements d un confrère
pakistanais qui devait nous accompagner
qui est arrêté ensuite on a plus le bon
chauffeur on a une espèce de pleutres de
chauffeurs lequel je n'ai aucune
confiance et j'aurais dû m'écouter à ce
moment là effectivement alors à ce
moment-là vous ayez une rivière a passé
il ya un bac vous êtes dans un break
vous sortez du break et vous savez quand
ils vont voir votre taille ils vont
comprendre que vous n'êtes pas une femme
et un homme mais ce qui est très
étonnant sur la culture talibane c'est
qu'à ce moment-là il n'ose pas vous
déshabiller ses sauces pas déshabiller
les femmes moi j'ai refusé quand même
quand je suis sorti sur le bac je me
suis accroupi très vite de façon à
dissimuler ma taille effectivement et
donc il avait quelques doutes puisque
j'étais avec gt avec le confrère
pakistanais qu'ils avaient reconnu mais
ils se sont donné le ton de mme observer
et puis finalement ils ont quand même
pas osé s'il était était sûr à 70% il
nous en dit plus tard mais c'est 30%
restants ça les gêne et donc ils ont
demandé une vieille femme devenir mme de
venir fouiller dont quatre mois j'ai
senti que c'était râpé j'ai enlevé la
baule a de meilleur et je me suis pris
un vieux coup de poing dans le dans le
dans l'oreille qui m'a assommé puis à
partir de là j'étais j'étais bien mouais
le sable était chaud et je me sente à
l'aise plus en faites pas et alors là
vous êtes arrêté au départ c'est assez
courtois l'interrogatoire ouais je passe
plutôt bien et la voyais arriver un type
qui s'appelle tu admires jawad alors
vous les descriptions extraordinaire mon
bouquin profil camus l'ip dédaigneuse
logiquement et vous avez cette phrase
tout en lui révèle une adolescence
frustré de celles qui forment les
bourreaux inspiré c'est vous sentez que
ce type a tellement souffert quand il
était petit qu'effectivement il déteste
la terre entière et là vous commencez à
vraiment flippé il a 24 ans vous
apprendra après que c'est un proche de
ben laden qui va le voir brun portant al
qaïda oui c'est le responsable des
services secrets pour l'ensemble du sud
de l'afghanistan considéré comme un
jeune prodige c'est vrai qu'il avait
quelques qualités n'était pas dépourvue
de cruauté il est responsable de
milliers d'arrestations arbitraires
djalal abad et 2 et 2 probablement
plusieurs dizaines d'exécutions dont
celle du fameux commandant abdul haq way
qui est ce ce commandant qui s'étaient
infiltrés en afghanistan pour tenter de
rallier les triples été tués tout de
suite qui a été tuée tout de suite parce
qu'à mon avis de l'été infiltré depuis
le départ alors vous au départ j'ai beau
leur dire que vous êtes journaliste et
vous traite d'espions un indice même les
français peuvent être espion ouais il y
avait une secte al déclarations
malencontreuses on peut pas leur en
vouloir mais du du ministère de la
défense qui avait dit nous avons des
espions en afghanistan je ne savais pas
je crois que c'était la veille où
je viens dans la gestion qui donne pas
les photos elle était d accord
donc j'étais un peu dans l'embarras
alors en fait ce qu'on appelle un city
tour c'est-à-dire un tour de ville vous
êtes exhibé vous est lapidé quand même
temps je prends des pirates est je
prends des pierres partout j'ai pas été
plus mal lotis dans la mesure où j'étais
debout donc j'étais en sang
effectivement mais mon un de mes
confrères pakistanais qui se trouvait à
l'arrière et et recevait des coups de
crosse des arabes parce qu'en fait il y
avait beaucoup d'arabes jalalabad est
donc je crois que on est resté 26 jours
ensemble en prison il n'a pas pu dormir
pendant 21 jours ils s'habillent était
bleu est alors plus tard quand vous en
parlerais avec vos geôliers
vous leur direz montréal pourquoi me
faire faire ce tour de la ville est
bloquée comme arme je leur reproche en
permanence au city tour eh oui je dise
bas nous c'est normal qu'on vous fasse
ça parce que nous on n'a pas la télé
pour annoncer votre capture comment vous
voulez qu'on fasse c'est insensé et 100
joueurs ouais alors al'inverse de ce
personnage un autre qui est beaucoup
plus sympa dans votre bouquin je vais le
karité hiver 1 alors lui il est
sympathique d'emblée vous le trouvez
c'est bien dans ce bouquin de ce cas le
méchant le jeu vous le trouver
sympathique d'emblée lépi peut-être
moins décérébrés par l'islamisme que les
autres il est entré en tas libanais un
peu par hasard et puis pour des pour des
intérêts ainsi il a ses idées il est ben
moi je le trouve assez sympa dans la
mesure où j'ai l'impression qui m'a
sauvé la vie oui effectivement je viens
à un moment ça l'ex ordinaire dans votre
bouquin c'est ça
et
c'est la sienne est absolument
incroyable on verra ça dans un film on
dirait le scénariste a pris de l'acide
vous êtes là par les bombardements
américains ou les talibans était sur le
toit de la prison et puis effectivement
je j'ai dû penser abandonnée sauf que
match a été longtemps installé sur les
champs-elysées donc je devais avoir une
vieille nostalgie et je me suis mis à
fredonner mais alors malgré moi parce
que j'avais une passion pour joe dassin
en particulier aux champs elysées et ils
l'ont retenu il adore chanter et c'est
comme ça que joe dassin et rentrer au
panthéon de la guerre
sur le toit de la prison les avions
américains dans le ciel
les talibans jubilant quand les frappes
commence moi j'arrive au deuxième jour
des frappes pour eux c'est c'est tout
bénef c'est la guerre a commencé le
djihad a commencé donc il y avait une
espèce de liesse très particulière avec
les tirs d'essai à le spectacle était
grandiose alors vous découvrez les
talibans de l'intérieur et ça c'est très
intéressant c'est en ça que votre livre
aussi très intéressant c'est à dire que
finalement on voit des gens qui sont
capable d'autodérision qui sont loin de
se moquer d'eux mêmes ils sont ils sont
marrants son joueur
il joue au volley ball ils veulent
constituer l'équipe des talibans pour
les jeux olympiques
les vrais méchants j'ai l'impression en
lisant votre bouquin c'est arabe sert
ceux qui sont venus et qui ont fait
souche là-bas quoi et qui s'est lassé la
grée la vraie découverte c'est à dire
moi je suis arrivé plutôt confiant ce
même après l'arrestation je pensais que
je pouvais m'en sortir en mesure où vous
avez fréquenté en 96 ce que j'avais
complètement mésestimé c'était une
importance qui avait pris les arabes et
étrangers découverte les talibans les
craignait pas réellement il en avait
peur il et d'écrivains prévisible
émotionnel alors pendant ce temps là
michel peyrard à l'extérieur il ya une
grande mobilisation pour vous évidemment
votre journal paris match qui s'occupe
très bien de ces algues grand reporter
quand ils sont dans la merde il faut le
dire les autorités françaises aussi bien
sûr et vous vous en doutez pas si vous
êtes dans cette prison et puis vous
savez pas tout ça vous en doutez un
petit peu mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment
où j'en doute même pas du tout je suis
je suis à ce point naïf que j'imagine où
on parle de libération c'est à dire à
partir du 12e jour j'imagine repartir
pas le même endroit très discrètement
par l' agence de mormant en remettant la
burqa
pourquoi voulons pas tuer au début
j'ai il était quelle ville il était
question qui me tue le premier soir
jusque quand carine ever donc le
directeur de la prison appelles tu as du
meilleur djaouad pour demander mon
shalwar kamiz donc la tunique
pakistanaise parce qu'on est là j'étais
pratiquement jeté torchwood je me jette
rien tu admires lui répond le français
est mort demain donc c'est pas la peine
de le détient
kaboul s'est opposé à notre exécution
des 2 ou 3 ieme jour je crois qu'on le
doit beaucoup à leurs fans qui donc mon
confrère pakistanais qui avaient aidé
des amitiés notamment aux ministères des
affaires étrangères et à partir de ce
moment là je crois que notre vie
n'étaient plus en danger le stock à ses
droits quand même c'était chaud
très chaud alors finalement les frappes
se précisant le 21 octobre à 22h la
prison des ménages mais pas des
journalistes donc voilà comment ont été
libérés et vous serez libéré de
l'enquêté
alors
le 22 février 2002 vous y retourner il
fallait que j'y retourne d'une part
parce que j'avais fait la promesse à
kahrizak peur de rendre le service qui
m'est rendu j'y allais pour le
réconcilier avec le nouveau régime j'y
vais parce que il a lancé un appel
désespéré peu après la chute de la ville
donc peu après la chute des taliban
lancé un appel désespéré au pakistan en
disant que j'ai de gros soucis
c'est quand même le type qui m'a sorti
de l'embarras